[Music]
[Laughter]
okay what's another good kitty let's do
it you trippin camera
[Music]
and a Bubo see you ready son
thank you very much good night yes all
charged up
congratulations
was there ever any doubt you heard the
part about this being a stuff operation
right what are you saying X 27 remember
oh come on that was not my fault we were
specifically told to bring the heat it
was very hot
just remember twinkle fist do you think
with your head not your hands she knows
right
we follow the beacon to the target
Minerva Atlas find elevation and provide
cover please the rest of you let's bring
Sola home
[Music]
we take a dip
does anyone else get a closer for
breaking these things nice scuba suit
you need a rad darling
about smile for me huh a smile yeah
nothing to help you at least you could
do is give me a smile how about a
handshake
I'm veers people call me the dawn Wow
here's a proposition for you
you're gonna give me your jacket your
home and your motorcycle and in return
I'm gonna let you keep your hands
[Music]
could we do a waterfall all the CG of
course you can but we did go to your
Wessel Falls and Victoria Falls in
Africa to get the richness of what that
environment was and then of course you
enhance but that reference is
irreplaceable when you have a flirtin
cool theory we know what a cat looks
like but you don't know what it flirting
looks like so then you have a little bit
of leeway and yet we always go back to a
known texture so that your eye is
tricked enough you see the furqan you go
well that makes little sense we take
what is practical which gives us the
best performance and then we help it and
then we do anything that is needed we
have a couple of da-jin moments this one
has been one of the biggest undertakings
for the aging that we've done did you
see her weapon I did not we have Colson
which is ten years but for Sam we did
more like almost 25 years 30 years Julie
mr. Sam hasn't changed much and yet you
can see he has I'm here to talk to you
about the Avenger initiative he's such
an iconic actor and everyone knows where
he is so if you do it wrong is very
clear and we have maybe 800 shots I tell
a lot of daj of Sam Jackson official
shield activity stay back
in a world where heroes and villains are
caught in a perpetual game of cat and
mouse the good guys only seem to scratch
the surface of justice filmmakers were
tasked with finding the most acclaimed
cats number to become an unlikely hero
with the power to move mountains what's
your name when we were working on the
first outline for this movie and we
shared it with Kevin Feige his first
note was we need two hundred percent
warm goose
oh my god get that thing away how's it
getting here
we gave yeah we gave it to him the cat
this isn't what you're afraid of is it I
saw the kind that's a flirt
good kitty in casting Marvel's most
ambitious role yet filmmakers had to
endure countless hours of cuddles
nozzles and possible allergy attacks we
auditioned a few different cats we ended
up with primarily a cat named Reggie the
play goose who looks like a cat but is
actually an alien called a Fleur Caen
species flirted threat hi
Reggie's unique sense of humor and
comedic timing were an asset to
filmmakers and his acting chops who's a
good kitty huh proved positively
ferocious that's right the thing that I
found so nice and Carol from reading the
comics was that sense of humor mixed
with total capability and whatever
challenge comes her way
modify this is not just somebody who is
incredibly powerful and can shoot photon
blasts out of the arm it's somebody
who's very vulnerable and has multiple
dimensions Kelly sue became a really
great asset for us to be able to go to
and talk to about Carol how she saw the
character and what her foundational
principles were in writing what Carol
would be somebody that we root for when
they're super-powered like this all of
these characters have to be relatable
I keep having these memories
something in my past is the key to all
of this it's incredibly empowering for
women and girls because they haven't
made her a girl here oh she's just here
oh I'm not gonna fight your war I'm
gonna end it
you've always had powerful female
characters in our movies but having
Captain Marvel is the title character
for the first time
is a great foreshadowing for how Captain
Marvel is about to take the lead
and be at the forefront of the entire
cinematic universe I can't do this alone
we need you
[Music]
in practice gay was one of the first
action sequences that we started
storyboarding and pre-visit even before
we had a script we knew that that
sequence was an anchor for our story we
worked with different storyboard artists
to help us out like we go Dallas on girl
do we have any information we can act
all the scrolls are looking for the clue
to where the tesseract is what does it
feel if someone was trying to extract
that memory from your brain unless they
don't find it in a bank what she go we
really wanted to capture that feel for
when she's first coming to kind of open
up and then close again
she's so disoriented and she sees these
upside-down figures and the sound is all
murky and one of the fun things that
came out of the process was that shot
where we pulled back and turn around and
realize that she's upside down
Scrolls have invaded yet another border
planet
the relentless scroll expansion
dangerously nears our territory what's
very clever about storytelling in
Captain Marvel is that you're fed the
propaganda of one nation and believe
that the scrolls are the bad guys but
you only sing through the kree's eyes as
we meet the Kree in this movie they're
technologically driven and very much
motivated by this work which has kind of
become pervasive to their entire society
the Kree are a very dominant and very
aggressive race and their military and
their leaders conduct themselves as such
[Music]
the Kree are really incredible warriors
paper intellectuals and also totally
devoid of emotion you lied to me
I made you the best version of yourself
what we learn over of course the movie
is they won the war years ago and the
scrolls are living as refugees and the
Kree are kind of hounding them
mercilessly
[Music]
the handful of us that left will be
slaughtered next unless you help me
finish what Marvel started all right
here we go we're set
you've always had powerful female
characters in our movies but having
Captain Marvel is the title character
for the first time
feels like it's overdue and so we always
love to look for filmmakers who've done
incredibly special films and Anna Boden
right fleck have done just that they
just understood Carol and they
understood her story and that journey of
becoming a superhero Ryan and Anna came
in with an amazing perspective and
they've really put their own spin on the
material and give it a voice and a
spirit that's fresh
you guys wouldn't happen to know how
these things come off would you know
fine
I've seen time and time again directors
should be brought into the Marvel
Universe and really thrive the same
thing is true of Ryan and Anna they have
this intense enthusiasm for it and a
desire to kind of honor what's been set
up about these characters and also take
it somewhere new you're not a vlados
thing we'll see that's a yes or no
question yes
[Music]